when I got into standard 10 years ago
the question of what constitutes a wicon
was one with a single standout answer
ethering it was a control meta no doubt
if you weren't playing a devotion deck
or attempting in vain to play Green you
were playing one of the many variants of
control and you were almost certainly
running one or two copies of etherlink
as a way to close out the game for a
relatively new player it was a
comforting type of card you input a
bunch of mana and two or three turns and
in return it reduces your opponent's
life total to zero so
that's what a wicon is right or maybe a
wion is when my brother played an
overwhelming Stampede into a cluttered
board state to cut through my modest
Suite of blockers like a hot knife
through I don't know a handful of 44
vampires or maybe it was a wicon when I
played Angelic gift on a 44 land at the
Battle for zendar pre-release and
smacked my opponent four times for the
win above average 2 man enchantment
honestly some might even call it a
wingon we all come across the concept of
a wing condition somewhere along the
line in our existences as magic BL
players and this is for a reason mtg's
defense friendly combat system and hand
emptying Mana system means that it can't
always be assumed that the game will end
naturally that there are all sorts of
game situations that might sprawl out
and demand some sort of Remedy there are
lots of situations where the phrase wind
condition has a fairly understandable
meaning however as with most pieces of
terminology it becomes a lot more
challenging in Commander sex tling the
life total of your opponents makes a lot
of things challenging to be honest not
only does it take more to win an EDH
game but the concept of what winning
means shifts
wildly conventional EDH wisdom might
have you gesturing at various things as
a wicon creator of Behemoth is a wicon
torment of Hailfire is a wicon peros god
of the forge is a wicon sanguin bond is
a wicon and sure this classification
does work on some level there are lots
of situations where these cards will win
you the game and they each gesture at a
different plan for winning the game but
is this a useful category of card I
don't think it is anything can win a
game if your opponents Play No cards a
one- one squirrel is a quality wicon if
your opponents are playing nothing but
archers and bears a single Siege dragon
is a great wicon you shouldn't ask the
question what cards in my deck are the
ones that win the game because the
important question is what cards in my
deck are the ones that don't win the
game now let me clarify that last
statement what I don't mean to say is
that you should cram your deck full of
big splashy bombs quite the opposite
even having too high a density of Splash
in your deck will leave you twoo little
room for the building blocks that
actually lead to Victory what I mean
here is that if you're building a deck
with the intent of winning a game of
Commander that goal should be present in
some form or other throughout each and
every one of your card choices the
number one criticism I have for people
when they ask me to look at their deck a
criticism I give about half the time is
this looks unfocused this phrase can
mean a couple different things in
practice and to start thinking about
those it's useful to First lay out a
framework for how EDH decks work
fundamentally most decks involve a
system of inputs and outputs with inputs
being conditions that need to be met and
outputs being the results of those
inputs that contribute to the deck's
game plan my Sherm deck's primary inputs
are Astros slide and cycling cards and
its primary outputs are flickers which
allows sh room to recur large artifacts
onto the board my marad deex primary
input are equipments and its primary
outputs are Mana value and my commander
hitting your face for 14 damage I could
give more examples but long story short
inputs and outputs are the name of the
game for decks with any amount of
synergy and this framework itself points
us to the two places a deck can stumble
with regard to focus it can have
unfocused inputs and it can have
unfocused outputs for an example of a
deck with unfocused inputs a viewer
emailed me about their Missy deck that
contained both artifact creature and
face down creature Synergy packages with
a couple narrower sections of sub
synergies Within These within the deck
there are the components to make some
decently powerful board States but the
issue is that there are too many
different types of card and ability
present and they don't really connect
with each other outside of all being
related to the Commander in some form or
other ultimately a deck like this with
unfocused inputs will naturally have a
lot of dead draws and will struggle to
put together a cohesive board state with
any
consistency it's possible to build a
deck that can pivot between a few
different plans but these decks are
tricky to build and typically involve
paying close attention to the points of
connectivity between various types of
card some examples of decks with
unfocused outputs would be
conventionally built variants of what I
like to call Value tribal commanders and
I'll use Gaby Nest Warden as an example
since I've already talked about her
before your average Gaby deck is pretty
good at maintaining cycling based value
Loops but when we look at the actual
payoffs for cycling aside from draw it's
a lot of small token creation some
larger token creation some soft creature
removal some incremental damage some
creatures getting bigger and so on
theoretically you're getting a lot of
stuff when you add the input of cycling
but those outputs are so diverse that
these decks don't end up actually doing
any one thing in particular it's just a
flood of generic Magic the Gathering
gameplay this is probably better than a
deck with unfocused inputs since it's
actually doing something pretty
consistently but it's a generally
toothless type of deck that will
struggle to win against Decks that have
more refined win plans even if those
decks generate a smaller quantity of
total
resources both unfocused inputs and
unfocused outputs are problems that will
lead to challenges in ending the game
but for different reasons despite this
the solution to the two problems is
pretty similar you should be asking what
each card in your deck does how often it
will fail to perform its intended
function and whether it contributes
toward a cohesive plan for your deck a
common first step is in building
Commander decks is to lump together a
bunch of cards that synergize around a
particular one or two things and while
this will lead to a deck that does do
something if you're trying to win games
it might take a bit of tuning beyond
that to make sure the deck can actually
make it to the finish line and for a bit
I want to zoom in on a particular type
of deck that often Falls just a little
short in this regard all right so this
is a transition point in a longer video
where it might make sense to put a mid
roll ad but I don't like mid roll ads so
I don't run them on my videos that said
if you like what I do and have a spare
three bucks a month to support me in
making high effort videos like this one
there's a link to my patreon down in the
description as I was going through the
Ed treack page for Gaby while writing
the previous section there was one
standout exception to the lack of good
options for closing out the game that
being Moon Shaker Cavalry the card is a
brutally efficient finisher capable of
converting a board full of tokens into a
bunch of dead opponents in short order
and its presence here gestures at a
specific type of card Mass buff cards
whose usage could lead to a gabby Deck
with a more definite identity this
brings me to the subject of mid-range
which I'll Define here as Decks that
want to get a big board of creatures and
then attack with them now I'm sure when
play testing we all like to imagine the
ideal scenario for a beat down deck we
play out a bunch of creatures and swing
into The Big Empty Boards of our
quivering hypothetical opponents and
this might occasionally be the case but
in most games your opponents will have
creatures as well even if their deck
isn't a purely mid-range deck so here
I'm going to introduce an important
phrase parody parody means a state of
standstill basically and in the
mid-range context it's usually when
multiple players have decent sized
boards but can't swing in for large
damage due to a lack of evasion or a
risk of Counterattack in a game like
this with multiple mid-range e decks we
can divide the game into two key steps
for a given player create parody and
break parody creating parody just means
getting your beefy mid-range board up
and going and not falling behind
this sounds simple and indeed it's not
too hard in the abstract but there are
lots of places to go wrong you can fail
to draw Mana fail to draw beaters fail
to draw the right combinations of
beaters and even if you succeed at these
three things you can still get board
wiped or lose to a non-combat wicon
before you're able to do an adequate
quantity of beating for this reason
lands ramp draw protection and a varied
mixture of creatures might all be parts
of how you get into a state of parody
with other decks breaking parody is
where you do something to the board that
allows you to deviate from the state of
parody which generally means letting
your creatures hit for a lot of damage
the most popular parody Breakers in
Commander are overrun effects but there
are a myriad of other potential options
targeted Buffs go extra combat spells
Mass evasion spells and cards that
disable potential blockers or even
remove them all together I am on the
record saying that mass calcify is the
best evasion spell now if I were to rank
these in terms of raw power the bigger
overrun effects like crater hoof
Behemoth and finale of Devastation would
be easily top of the pile with moon
Shaker Cavalry being a similarly
powerful option in white however I'd
argue that these are also probably the
least interesting options as well given
how straightforward and hard to interact
with they are so if you're not playing
at a super high power level you should
go with whatever parody breaker feels
most appropriate to you the important
thing is that you should have at least
something for this some number of cards
played with the goal of converting that
cool board you worked hard to build up
into a win with all of that said and to
crib shamelessly from EDH Rec cast one
challenge in navigating parody Breakers
is being able to distinguish a card that
helps you win from a win more card the
goal of a parody breaker should be to
turn a game State that's not quite
winning into one that wins but some
cards will only win with a board state
that was probably already about to win
for example epic struggle wins the game
outright if you you have 20 or more
creatures on your upkeep but there are
tons of cards that can win off of a
board that massive and most will be
useful in situations with fewer
creatures as well rather than being a
four Mana enchantment with no text
Crucible of fire is a less extreme
example it's an Anthem for a creature
type that's generally already quite big
and most Dragon decks would probably be
better served by running an additional
dragon with useful abilities instead
ultimately the way to navigate these
sorts of cards is just to think about
all the situations in which a given card
is useful and also the situations where
it's not useful if something is a kind
of dead card 2third of the time that
other third had better be really good
parody also exists as a relevant concept
outside of mid-range decks specifically
for aggro and control decks for an aggro
deck parody is what you want to avoid
and if your momentum does come to a bit
of a stall as your opponents catch up on
board you at least want them to be low
enough on life or other resources to be
deeply uncomfortable in their position
within in the game this is the general
conceit of a lot of 60 card burn decks
throw creatures at your opponent's face
until you can't anymore and then hope
you got your opponent low enough to
finish them off with burn in time
control on the other hand is similar to
the classical mid-range parody plan in
the sense that it's looking to create
and then break it but is very different
in that control decks will often create
parody by using board wipes or Stacks
pieces that slow down the table and then
break parody using carefully picked out
cards that are less affected by these
tools
control decks are also typically chiefly
worried about Resource Management
compromises must be made between how
scary the board is allowed to be and how
many control spells are kept in hand for
contingencies for these reasons control
is sometimes easier to finish off
opponents with than mid-range since
small boards and suppressive methods
mean that less potent finishers can
still do the job and that winning over
the course of several turns is
acceptable you do still need to think
about the deck's win plan though and
balancing that with the deck's
controlling element is naturally going
to be part of the challenge on that note
let's talk about removal in a more
General sense based on the amount of
removal people seem to run in casual EDH
it seems like a lot of people might not
be aware of this but if one of your
opponents wins the game your odds of
winning that game actually drop quite
precipitously you might have a bit of a
hard time pulling off that W so seeing
as how this is snail's guide to winning
an EDH game it is my duty to tell you
that preventing your opponents from
winning the game is an important concern
that you shouldn't take lightly however
despite my smartassery I understand why
people tend to run low removal counts
let's assume for a moment that we're
thinking about the archetypal removal
spell a spell that destroys a spooky
thing on our opponent's board that may
or may not lead to our demise if left
unchecked for every removal spell you
add to your deck you're increasing your
ability to hinder your opponents but
you're also subtracting from slots
available to bolster your own game plan
for for this reason you can think of
these removal spells as being something
that buys you time at a cost as a side
effect of this faster decks won't need
as many removal spells as slower decks
and I'm going to demonstrate why that is
visually let's think about the amount of
stuff that needs removing at a given
moment when I think of really spooky
stuff that begins to happen in a game it
generally starts up small where say 10%
of the time there will be some
potentially game-ending nonsense on a
given turn but things will pick up for
the next few turns until you're at the
point where there's going to be spooky
stuff left and right the timing and what
exactly comprises potentially Game
ending nonsense will vary with power
level but the basic concept stays fairly
constant and you can shift around this
scale as needed let's say you're playing
at a somewhat middling power level where
you're going to start seeing power plays
trickling out around turn five with
things getting really intense by turn 9
or so assuming the game goes that long
if you're playing a faster deck say one
that's looking to start knocking down
opponents around turn six there's a lot
of stuff you simply won't need to deal
with because your opponents won't have
time to fully develop it out before
you're threatening lethal by contrast if
you're playing a slower deck that's
looking to develop a much more
all-encompassing threat a bit later in
the game there's a good chance you'll
need to contend with some threatening
plays from your opponents before you're
able to pull off your win since player
removal is not an option you'll still
want some ways to slow down your
opponents in a faster deck but you won't
need nearly as many another
consideration is that interaction isn't
always just about stopping your
opponent's win plans it can also remove
obstacles to your wind plan with a given
flame slash you could be killing your
opponent's Volo guide to monsters to
prevent them from doing some dumb
with it but you could also be deleting
somebody's glissa so you can swing at
them with your offensively large
attacker or getting rid of their archon
of a Maria so you can have your
ridiculous Popoff turn unimpeded this
sort of flexibility is also where
counter spells really shine you can
always counter that Jing axius or tur
grid but you can also counter a board
wipe or a removal spell lobed at your
key creature I personally really like
counter spells and usually run at least
eight in my decks with blue and I'll run
more if the wind plan is more fragile
such as one that is slow and board-based
or a combo without backup options
counter spells do have their downsides
though there's the holding up mana
problem where if you hold up mana for a
Potential Threat and the threat doesn't
materialize you've effectively wasted
Mana as opposed to a removal spell where
you can wait for a threat to materialize
and then deal with it at your next
convenience counter spells are still
fantastic and can deal with some higher
powerered threats that are Untouchable
by normal removal but they require a bit
more thought to fit into a game plan and
might not be right for all decks
regardless it's worthwhile to put in the
thought and to consider what types of
interaction will best bolster your win
plan and whether it might be worth it to
play a bit more in a given
deck I think it is mentioning that
everything I've said so far in this
video is meant in the context of a game
where decks are similarly matched in
terms of power level and where players
are on the same page about what
constitutes a fun game of Magic the
Gathering the most foolproof way to win
a game of EDH is to obliterate a bunch
of precons with a goo cedh deck so I
guess if that's what you clicked on this
video for there you go but I'd say that
sort of gameplay is not interesting for
anybody in addition for any given card
that might be considered a finisher
there will be plenty of players who
aren't interested in using it and others
who would rather not play against it and
navigating that is a key step in having
fun while playing a casual social format
while this video is about how to win an
EDH game my target audience here is less
so Decks that are already well-rounded
and looking to pump their power level
and more so Decks that are doing some
cool things but are struggling to find
their way to wins there's a good chance
that improving your deck's ability to
win will make it feel more powerful
overall but my point here is simply that
you should achieve that by playing to
your deck's strengths and improving its
internal cohesion rather than just
windmill slamming crater H Behemoth or
torment of Hailfire into it and calling
it a day I also didn't really discuss
combo in this video because I feel like
combos are often conceptually more
straightforward than other types of win
options since though you can build a
multivalent combo family that can
navigate around five different types of
stacks effect on the most basic level
combo decks tend to be more of a yes or
no proposition when it comes to winning
compared to a conventional aggro
mid-range or control deck I also made a
full video about combo a while back and
I'll Briefly summarize a couple points
from that video here putting a combo in
your deck can be a great way to win a
game but you should accept that if you
throw a combo in your mid-range deck if
that combo is a lot better than your
mid-range win plan you're not playing a
mid-range deck you're playing a weird
inconsistent combo deck below higher
Powers the best type of combo to to put
in your deck will be one that requires
some degree of setup but setup that fits
naturally into the rest of the deck's
game plan and whose pieces have
alternate use cases in your deck combo
is basically Synergy taken to the
extreme so combos should ideally emerge
from trying to optimize your synergies
not from throwing sanguin Bond and
exquisite blood into a random black deck
to recap some general pointers from
earlier making your deck do a better job
of winning will often just mean making
sure the inputs and outputs are FOC
focused keeping your inputs focused
typically just means having enough deck
cohesion that your deck can launch into
a game plan off of its first 10 or 15
cards it draws you can think of this as
having a wide onramp you want as many
cards as possible that feel good early
to give your deck the best chances of
getting into gear keeping your outputs
focused means that once your deck gets
up and going the things that it does all
contribute to a cohesive game plan
that's moving in the direction of
Victory if you're making a deck that
does a lot of a particular thing such as
discarding cards or sacrificing
artifacts it's tempting to just throw in
all sorts of cards that have fun effects
when those things happen but doing that
will just add filler that doesn't help
you win windc cons don't exist in the
sense that you're going to have a bad
time if you smash together a deck and
then throw in a handful of splashy cards
at the end for the purpose of winning
but put a bit of thought in from the
start of where your deck wants to be
going and you'll have a pretty good
chance of getting there